premier titre à la une le contrôle des
changes et les vacances finalement de
toutes les mesures présentées par le
gouvernement celle qui de manière
épidermique peut être fait le plus
réagir le plus parler ce n'est pas
l'épargné forcée et l'impôt obligatoire
mais le rétablissement du contrôle des
changes
assortie de l'interdiction des cartes de
crédit à l'étranger qu'un certain nombre
de français ressentent comme une
limitation de leur liberté individuelle
et qui dès ce matin a provoqué la colère
des professionnels du tourisme qui se
sont rendus à la réunion du comité
directeur du parti socialiste pour
chahuter le nouveau ministre du commerce
extérieur et du tourisme madame edith
cresson patricia sharman ce matin donc
en pleine réunion des socialistes des
professionnels du tourisme pénètre à
l'assemblée nationale edith cresson
ministre du commerce extérieur et du
tourisme accepte de les recevoir
quelques instants s'engage alors un
dialogue impromptue et conscience de
cela nous sommes une profession qui
devint cela signifie nous allons prévoir
vraiment la mentalité des déçu déclare
je pense nationale ça va être la bonne
mobilisation totale des mines sim
permettait aux copains c'est quelque
chose
ainsi c'est sur une autre fois c'est que
cette décision risque de mettre en péril
la survie de pays entiers tels que la
tunisie la grèce le maroc l'espagne
l'italie et aidera qui vink en tout cas
déjà recevoir
si petit si de même réuni 6 2007 il
reçoit plus de touristes français ils
pourront recevoir ce parti ne prend
qu'une ont pu acheter du matériel
français 73 mettre en péril l'économie
française en général par une décision
qui nous paraît peut-être sage
certainement risotto rapidement et nous
pensons que quand l'huile de ce que vous
la prenez actuellement de votre métier
dans le tourisme vous pouvez encore à
portée des yeux ronds qu'elle soit
appliquée ces décisions seront
certainement pas rencontrer de partager
dans les alliages et messieurs je vous
convie
comme je vous ai d'ailleurs déjà convié
dans ma réponse à votre télégramme à
nous rencontrer sérieusement autour
d'une table à mon ministère mais c'est
certainement pas dans ces conditions tu
as tellement mais est-ce que vous avez
conscience qu'il est très impopulaire
tout à fait j'ai conscience qu'elle est
très impopulaire parce que bien sûr les
français sont à l'époque où beaucoup
d'entre eux ont déjà prévu leurs
vacances et je sais effectivement que
quand on a prévu contre un projet qu'ils
se trouvent contre carrer c'est toujours
difficile à accepter mais je te dire
d'abord que de telles dispositions déjà
été prises dans le passé
en 1968 les exportations de devises pour
les touristes étaient autorisés jusqu'à
700 francs seulement là il y à 2000
francs + 1000 francs par enfant
naturellement ça ne permet pas de grands
projets de vacances et les français
doivent effectivement se dire que en
acceptant je ne dis pas de gaieté de
coeur je me rend très bien compte des
difficultés que cela entraîne
mais en acceptant dans un certain esprit
de discipline et de solidarité
ces dispositions il se prive un peu mais
il se prive un peu tour un avenir et un
résultat qui sera meilleur et qui leur
permettra sans doute à la fois de sauver
leur emploi de redresser l'économie de
faire face à une situation
effectivement social que nous jouons
meilleur et donc ils contribuent je
dirais non pas passivement mais ils
peuvent contribuer activement à au
redressement de la situation économique
et vous pensez que seuls les vacances de
cette année seront concernées qu'il
faudra aussi serrer la ceinture année
prochaine
non je pense que seuls les vacances de
cette année sont concernés sans que tout
à fait évident